virgi i wonder uh
when you look at what they've done
editorially it's fairly interesting that
this has become a dominant media brand
and a sub
dominant
cable channel
i mean john stewart's done an amazing
job establishing a brand that
millennials actually want to tune into
and listen to and the way that he's done
that essentially is by being fearless
and calling bs on politicians and
on media itself every day
uh in particular you know the daily
aspect of it is fairly uh enormous just
in how often it's been there but are
there certain things that have put this
show on the map that let us sort of
leapfrog other traditional media
nightly news you know what whatever
other voices were coming at that same
generation but not reaching them
in terms of in terms of reaching them i
mean jon stewart has done a great job
with comedy central has done a great job
in terms of putting it on mobile putting
it on facebook putting it on social
which is really where the news is and
where people are consuming the news so
as they've adapted over the last 17
years they've really adapted to where
the news is going and where young people
especially are consuming the news
yeah it's fairly amazing that the what
they've done with digital and how
successful that's been because when this
show launched you know or when john
stewart joined the show well after the
show launched uh that could let us not
forget the great craig kilbourne years
but i wonder you know they surely
weren't thinking about new media when
they launched this old media show you
know cable tv talk show had been done
for a while um what is it in particular
that worked for them in new media
well again i think it was just the
adaptability that they were able to do
and do it very quickly um it's been
interesting to watch larry wilmore and
the nightly show because he has launched
in 2015 when people are already
consuming news on snapchat consuming it
on messenger apps like kik
and now this has definitely taken
advantage of the mobile video
opportunity so just in terms of
shareability and in terms of clips and
segments that you can get from those
shows comedy central has really done a
fairly outstanding job in adapting to
social consumption
yeah and of course there have been so
many people you mentioned larry wilmore
has just launched this new show there
but in the last few weeks but there have
been so many others who've gone on to
great big things from that show
some of uh most of whom are gonna be
pretty busy but he wonder how many might
be considered uh as the replacement for
jon stewart i know i think the cnn money
headline that they ran with today was
did comedy central lose three of their
biggest stars in a year or two years so
the timing is a little bit unfortunate
it was summer of 2013 when john oliver
stepped in and guests hosted the daily
show that summer some people wondered if
he was up to the job he did an amazing
job he landed his own successful series
on hbo
it's unfortunate that he can't just take
over because i think he'd be the natural
replacement but at least the daily show
has a good stable of correspondence and
very diverse correspondents and jessica
williams and officers monvi and samantha
b who they can choose from to maybe
establish their own brands and take over